speak of dramatic yes here we go here we
go Chef Dove oh man sh this is a weird
angle to bring it you could have brought
it over there it doesn't work at lugers
it it doesn't work at lugers Holy okay
okay now did you warm them up listen
that's this is [__] silly right here
hold on this is not warmed up this is
not warmed up warm oh they are they're
about 15
seconds warm okay so pleas [__] here we
go all right okay now I I believe just
do you have all you know everything okay
I believe this is Milton right no other
way oh sorry this is Milton so if you
want you can start with Milton do you
want to know where each are from or do
you want to kind of be a little
surprised let me do it blind okay go
blind I wish I didn't tell you about
right I'll try Milton's last I know what
Milton tastes like we also we got the
mil for you right there
now that's a sleeper that
one if you get this
though if you get
this I'm having the hardest time not
jumping in so I jump in that's good for
me yeah love the chewiness of that yeah
fantastic that reminds me of a oh I know
this of a cookie that you used to be
able to buy in the Bronx and they would
warm it up for you right there in the
store do you want to know where from let
me guess let's let let's let him yeah
let him work that's not it's not miss
it's um spunk Meer is the Otis spunk
Meer for the Otis spunk which one is
that that's Subway ah and you were kind
of right when you
said a spunk spunk it is might be a is
dog it is it's a spunk mire okay that's
F bro Subway is Oda spunk Mar holy [__]
wow bro [__]
[__] hit him with the Adam
Silver it was a
wink that's crazy that is crazy
crazy prize pick is going to match 100%
of that initial deposit bonus up to $100
so that means tail the picks go to the
playoff game of course both of those
okay but what does that mean that means
that if you put in a 100 they're also
giving you a 100 then you go tles picks
now you're going to watch a a damn
playoff game like there's an absolute
no-brainer let's get back to all right
he just cracked a
code
okay that was a good crunch this one
here
mhm I like that it's nice and crunchy
right oh that one's [__] delicious my
which one that fluffy guy I tend to like
a chocolate chip cookie that doesn't
have too many chocolate chips in it bro
I feel that way I don't like I don't
like chocolate chunk I like the cookie
tastes better than I like the you feel
me I don't like the Chun want more you
want extra chocolate in
oh my God then just eat chocolate you
know what I mean yeah that one godam
this one with the crunch might be the
best the crunch is stupid right I think
I know which one that is this one is the
texture is ridiculous I think I might
know that one is this leevan no is that
culture I'm not sure that is culture
that's culture where's that culture
espresso it's on like 36th Street I
think culture6 great I never knew that
that's really good I'm not even eating
that's how fat I am I Knew by looking
that's what I've been trying to do I've
been trying to figure it out this is
special little sea salt mhm sweet and
salt
is look beautiful that looks crazy the
way it just broke apart like
Artisan now this is crazy it's a valona
chocolate break it break it break it oh
no I good this is CRA I had that one
already this is this is one people are
saying is is the
cookie right
now the OG young
Milton there should be honey butter on
there we didn't do the honey butter for
a
reason we felt like it was like adding
ice cream yeah it's too much yeah like
it cheats
itain the additional thing yeah yeah
that's excellent as far as flavor yeah
Milton's cookie is the best wow the
flavor of the cookie now my wife made
these they're really good she did a
[__] tremendous job yeah for real
oh wow it's a delicious cookie you know
like text great too that vanilla paste
that's what I'm saying that's the
difference between everything is that
vanilla paste you get like it's a
special
cookie so this is
Mercer it's good the chef it's good it's
friends with Russ and that he was the
one told no that's good that's a good
cookie MH this crunch is the best that
one's crazy bang for buck you go Subway
100% bang for the buck you go spunk May
dog cuz those I'm telling you you these
could be warmed up in the microwave 12
times nothing CH it'll always
be it'll always be the same mhm okay
this is my wife's chocolate chip
cookie you got to get in
there lot of pressure bro brown butter I
can
ask that's really good too smooth
really good you heard it bab a great
job yeah this is a real schmus Borg over
here this one is crazy cuz it's soft and
crunchy some where's that one from this
is the culture this one right here you
guys should try for the vanilla flavor
in it that one has like a special it has
something to it bro it's like you don't
really taste things like that yeah she
nailed that [__] she killed it right she
nailed it and that when that comes out
that comes out really soft
like you got to let that sit for 20
minutes before you can even take it off
the pan that's up there with the subway
cookie
right that's up there that's up there a
[__] big deal that's a big deal dog
apartment 4f is this
one I used to live in
4J let me see there's a line out the
door of that place this morning really
for that place has a line I used to live
right by it is it only for cookies or
was it what what else they French
bakery
the whole deal my f my favorite French
bakery is by far BC clet bro oh yeah I
saw that episode that was great no it's
by far he's he's he's the illest dude
ever he makes all the bread himself he
was he was great he was great and he
wasn't like pretentious like what you
would think a French Baker would be he
was a friendly CU he's Ukrainian you
know he's like a Ukrainian
Frenchman yeah that whole place is crazy
classic sandwiches they do bro sh
roule I love that y this one's crazy
love I love the are [__] crazy
culture is crazy
crazy and Yasser me used to go there all
the time that crazy